ciao ragazzi per tornato in un nuova
puntata di cucina buttata adesso noi
italiani sappiamo che a livello
culinario condividiamo il podio
dell'eccellenza con pochissimi altri
paesi a livello proprio di materia prima
e ricette in generale piatti e
tradizione però allo stesso tempo da
grandi poteri derivano grandi
responsabilità questo vuol dire che il
più delle volte quando qualcuno non si
comporta bene in cucina noi siamo i
primi a stanarlo e primi soprattutto a
creare un bel insieme di odio nei
confronti del prossimo un povero
francese ha creato un po di tempo fa un
video nel quale faceva vedere come
faceva la carbonara
ora questo tizio è stato forse uno dei
più odiati del 2017 credo ed è così che
mi sono detto un secondo odio le persone
che criticano senza sapere una cosa
interessante sarebbe stata quella di
provare questa ricetta e vedere se
effettivamente da romano è approvata
colture no scusate se sorrido ma con un
po di paura per la prima salute per la
mia incolumità
che dire partiamo ci sono un sacco di
persone che se con i tutorial di altre
persone con cui noi seguiamo il tutorial
di una pippa in cucina forse peggio
ancora di me per fare questa carbonara
scena servono scarse doti culinarie
farfalle il tipico taglio di pasta per
la carbonara
perché si sa le farfalle muoiono in un
giorno ed è quello che più o meno è
successo a tutte le persone che hanno
testato questa ricetta a casa loro
interi andrebbe la pancetta ma noi non
ce l'abbiamo fatta quindi abbiamo
comunque preso di guanciale stick perché
non si poteva nuovo fermo lì e pecorino
anche se in realtà lui mentre il
parmigiano però non ce la facevamo delle
cipolle pepe
cos'è questa prezzemolo che si sa anche
essere un potente veleno se ingerito
quantità abbondanti che vuol dire che a
fine pasto potremmo comunque decidere di
finir cielo tutto quanto a crudo e lei
pesa più di una pistola in mano in
questo momento la panna da cucina perché
c'è in francia avete una cucina
buonissima oltre che fare la carbonara
fate l'escargot lele fondi cioè quelle
cose in cui termini francesi leticia
alessandro nel mon blanc nota a
carbonara
vediamo un pochino che cosa ha fatto
farfan
[Musica]
ok
dobbiamo tagliare una cipolla che poi la
cipolla nella carbonara lucci l'altro mi
sembra il minimo perché le altre conosco
un ragazzo che ci mette la cipolla e la
sua carbonare molto buona mettete la
cipolla ma io dubito che stiamo seguendo
uno chef stellato lo sai che tecnica è
solo un po confuso che poi lui la taglia
così non la taglia a pezzetti
ok va bene io seguo quello che vedo a
questo punto lui prende la cipolla e la
mette in un lato della ventola così
prendiamo il guanciale si hanno iniziato
a sbagliare non parla parla parla
prende il guanciale e lo mette sempre un
lato di lato in realtà non prende il
guanciale prende la pancetta
[Musica]
aspetto ha bisogno di un mucchio di un
momento c'è lui lui guarda gli
ingredienti stanno cercando di scappare
riprende le farfalle e le mette crude in
un angolo era più difficile quanto non
pensassi davanti acqua acqua 15 minuti a
fuoco dolce cosa esce da qua dentro
bicottura ragazzi a est è capito io me
ne sto già lavando le mani di questa
cosa non è la ricetta mia mettiamo un po
di acqua dentro bamba mia mamma mia che
porcata facciamo andare a 15 minuti a
fuoco dolce poter riprendere a questo
punto un mestolo anche una scopa usata
per permettere giu la pasta perché non
credono a questo punto importi si
incollano sceglie qualcosa di strano
non lui non gira via niente la prende e
la mette direttamente dai fornelli su
sul pavimento
ho capito vicino alla ciotola del cane
che sarebbe stato divertente vedere come
dire stagnari interpretano i piatti
italiani sembra di stare all'interno di
un film horror in questo momento cioè io
penso che adesso vi chiamerà qualcuno mi
dirà sette giorni
anzi sette chili ogni volta che in
francia succede questo in italia una
massaia schioda come le fatine di peter
pan e sta facendo schiuma quel tipo di
grasso e cose cosa ho fatto
perdonatemi io chiedo scusa in questo
momento aggiungere la panna mi sembra
non lo so una mossa valida da cracco da
bollendo sta bollendo e quindi adesso
dovrebbe bollire per a tipo 10 minuti
così almeno viene bene al dente nel
senso che prendi i denti che li butti
via le gengive io sento quel timer che
sembra quello di una bomba a orologeria
pronto a scoppiare finirà il mondo
appena sentirò e qui due cose si
baceranno sta amalgamando da solo
io spero se magni pure da solo buono
croccante il guanciale presentato o di
ragazzi qui ci sono delle patatine
fritte ma non possiamo derubare per la
cia scooter e giocatori né fritte
siamo però lasciandogli un bel piatto di
pasta da sono delle patatine classiche
come la recente che stiamo facendo
ma poi enrico scusa ti rovini l'appetito
non esce con un cattivo odore
quello però poi pensa che quella roba lì
alla fine una carbonara sconvolti dalla
puntata la bontà dobbiamo essere
obiettivi per il momento quello che
abbiamo fatto è stato abominevole da qui
vado in chiesa mi confesso poi posso
proseguire la mia giornata
non bisogna prenderlo con un piatto di
pasta era materia utilizzata in maniera
diversa ma tipo legna per il camino che
magari è altamente infiammabile la butta
lì e fi cioè un barbecue pazzesco si
accomoda 7 moretta tre minuti e mezzo in
questo momento questo bollore lo senti
un interprete della natura direbbero
anno bestemmiando quei pezzi di
guanciale con che è uno scempio alla
lista lei ora mescolata per ingolosire
il pubblico
ha una consistenza pari se non è quella
del bostik cioè se vuoi ora la lancia
dalla finestra che sta qui rimbalza
sull'asfalto il ritorno a bocca
considera che sembra che i rimbalzi il
cucchiaio quando il pergine scavare più
di così il fuoco ad essere più dolce
però sta facendo il possibile per
alterare la ricetta posso dirlo non
dovevamo metterci la pancetta infatti
non dovevamo mettere guanciale dobbiamo
metterci in forma di parmigiano una
polvere al formaggio e non è pecori simo
pecorino romano di opi siamo parando ok
carbonara tra miss over infilzata solo
volerlo gli utenti questa cucina sono
cercato di fermarmi
giriamo sentita per la francese scusa
rimpiazziamo preparatevi
perdonami ti prego scusami non ci posso
fare ma che c'entra adesso questo cosa
c'è inter prezzemolo adesso siete seduti
a casa
se siete tipo in metro in questo momento
in qualche posto dove sta in piedi
siete magari infine alle poste sedetevi
odiosa secondo voi ci hanno messo
abbastanza da renderlo immortale poi di
per se l'accoppiata degli ingredienti
che renderà immortale
ed ecco la nostra carbon ora si dice qui
buon appetito ci aggiunge un altro
pochino di pepe e chiude il video con un
buon appetito migliore chiuso con bella
per il bene della scena il visitatore è
l'unione tra uno spaghetto alle vongole
nuovo e questo stufato di cipolle il
guanciale presente quando tiri fuori dai
brody di carne pezzo di carne stufato
stessa cosa so che non è un brodo uno
scenario a mi raccomando ragazzi
prendete uovo tutto bravo
mammamia gianmarco se però dio santo
svendendo tutto ad ora io mi rifiuto ma
prendiamo un bel boccone file data dalla
mediate così tanto alla tua sentite lo
spaghettone gommone questa maionese ben
disgustoso e terrificante a me si
stringe il cuore che dall'alto
dall'altra parte dell'europa però della
magia perché sto facendo un analisi per
capire quanto mi si stringe il cuore per
il fatto che d'altra parte dell'europa
qualcuno consiglieri questa roba italia
una carbon a italia poi dici perché
siamo suscettibili no che vorrei fare un
appello che sia ma c'è che cosa aveva in
testa a cosa stai pensando il giorno in
poi postato un video nel quale faceva
questo mi stanno chiamando è la polizia
ragazzi
io vi chiedo scusa se chiudiamo questo
video con una nota amara con retrogusto
amaro che è più o meno quello che
abbiamo noi in questo momento in bocca
però vorrei fare un appello a quella
persona e non ha mostrato il suo viso
se qualcuno anzi lo può tradurre in
francese qua sotto perché io non so
parlarlo che devo smettere a tutti quei
carboidrati non meritano un trattamento
simile
e con questo titolo è fatto ammalare il
mio fratello alla prossima domenica con
una ricetta è forse un pizzico di
allegria più che schifo
mia madre santa